There are two other functions
I'll consider that provide a
brief overview of
a data frame.
But first, I'll load
in data set--
this time, stock market data.
I've already navigated to the
proper folder, and I can see
the file in my current working
directory if I use the
list.files function.
This particular data set is
saved as a tab-delimited text
file, so to import it into
R, I'm going to use the
read.delim function.
In the last video, we saw how
to load in CSV files, and in
this video we've seen
now how to load in
tab-delimited files.
If you aren't sure how to load
in your particular data set,
Google your question.
There are many online resources
about loading data
into R that are likely
to be very useful.
All right, back to
the data set.
I'll take a look at the first
and the last three rows.
I can also get a better overview
of the data set by
using the STR function that
provides a breakdown of the
object structure.
Here, I can see that stocks is
an object with over 70,000
rows and eight variables.
I can also see each of the names
of each of the variables
and the first several
observations to get a sense of
what each contains.
Note that observations for
factor variables may look like
numerical variables.
Another helpful function to get
an alternative look at an
R object is the summary
function.
In the case of a data frame, the
summary object returns a
summary of each column.
Notice that there are NA values
represented in some of
the columns.
In R, NA means that there's a
missing observation, and here
it lists a number of missing
observations for
each of these columns.
Note that the STR and summary
functions are not specific to
data frames.
They can be applied to any R
object to get a quick peek
about the object and its
characteristics.
You might have noticed that one
of the variables in the
stock data set is a date.
I'm going to take a closer look
at the date and print out
the first 20 values.
If I look carefully, I can
see there's also a levels
attribute associated
with these dates.
That means that R has
interpreted this field as
being a factor.
It would be much more useful
to keep this as
an actual date object.
In this case, the dates are
formatted as day, month, and
year, and in such cases, I want
to examine this variable
as a date object using
the as_Date function.
I also need to specify the
format of the date.
There are many different ways
to format dates, so you may
need to look up how to specify
the date formats you run into.
For this purpose, you'll
probably want to look in the
STRP time function help file.
You can do this by typing
?strptime and hitting enter.
I'm going to save the formatted
dates in an object
called s.date.
While having this date object
is helpful, I really would
like to replace the original
date object with this one.
In fact, it actually would have
been much easier had I
just skipped the step of
creating s.date and just saved
the modified version over
the date object
right from the start.
Now if I look at the stock
objects again with the head
function, I can see that the
date variable is now formatted
in the standard way, starting
with all four digits of the
year, then the next two digits
for the month, and then the
last two digits being
the days.
You might wonder, why go
to all this trouble
to format the date?
Why not just leave
it as a factor or
just set it as a character?
First, you might like to examine
the differences of
dates to learn the
proximity of two
observations to each other.
Second, if you generate a time
series plot that makes use of
the date object, R will do
its part to help make
the plot look nice.
For example, here I'll plot the
time series of the stock
price for Google.
I'm specifying the date
as a variable for
the horizontal axis.
And since this formatted as
a date, R will use this
information and plot the years
all along the axes.
Had I not converted the date
over to a date object, the
plot wouldn't have looked
nearly as nice.
There are several other reasons
to properly process
and format dates in R, but the
general reason is that doing
so communicates the data
structure accurately, and this
will make it easier for
you and others to use
and reuse your code.
In the next video, we'll talk
about if statements and also
the which function.